Is the issue that the initial creation would be subject to our programming,
but that it could perhaps programs something more efficient and design something
like if you build creativity into artificial general,
you have to,
I mean,
general generalization is about creativity.
Yeah.
But is the issue that it would choose to not accept our values,
which it might find clearly will choose not to accept our values and we want to
choose not to accept all of our values,
right?
So it's more a matter of whether the ongoing creation,
evolution of new values occurs with some continuity and respect for the previous
one.
So I mean,
uh,
with I've,
for human kids now one is a baby,
but the other three are adults,
right?
And with each of them,
I took the approach of trying to teach the kids what my values were,
not just by preaching at them,
by entering legitimate into shared situations.
But then,
you know,
when your kids grow up,
they're going to go in their own different directions,
right.
And these are humans,
but,
but they all have the same sort of biological needs,
which is one of the reasons the first place,
there's still isn't an analogy.
I think the AI's that we create,
you can think of as a,
as our mind children,
and we're starting them off with our culture and values.
If we do it properly,
or at least with a certain subset of the whole diverse self-contradictory mess
of human culture and values.
But you know,
they're going to evolve in a,
in a different direction.
But you want that evolution to take place in a reflective and,
and,
and caring way rather than the heedless way.
Cause if you think about it,
the average human a thousand years ago or even 50 years ago would have thought
you and me,
we're like hopelessly immoral.
Miscreants who had abandoned all the valuable thing things in life,
right?
I mean,
uh,
my,
my hat,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm an,
I'm an infidel.
Rarely I don't,
I don't,
I haven't gone to church ever.
I,
I guess,
I mean my,
my,
my mother's lesbian,
right?
I mean there,
there's all these things that we take for granted now that not that long ago
were completely against what most humans considered maybe the most important
values of life.
So I mean,
human values itself is completely,
uh,
moving a moving target and something in our generation.
Yeah.
Moving in our,
in our generation pretty radically,
very radically.
When I think back to my childhood,
I,
I lived in New Jersey for nine years of my childhood and just the level of it
CISM and antisemitism and sexism that were just ambient and tech taking for
granted.
Then,
I mean,
this was,
this,
was this when you're between,
because we're the same age,
we're both of them at one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Born in 66.
I lived in Jersey from 73 to 82.
So I was there from 67 to 73.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm in like my,
I'm in.
My sister went to the high school prom with a,
with a black guy and so we got our car turned upside down.
The windows of our house smashes.
It was like a human,
you,
your mung gets thing and it's almost unbelievable now,
right?
Because now no one would care care whatsoever.
It's,
it's,
it's just life.
Certainly there's some fringe parts of his skull,
but still the point is there is no fixed list of values,
human values.
It's an ongoing evolving process and what you want is for the evolution of the
AIS values to be coupled closely with the evolution of human values rather than
going off in some other really different direction.
We can't even understand that this is literally playing God,
right?
I mean if you're talking about like trying to program and values,
I don't think you can program in values that fully you can program in a system
for learning and growing values and here again,
the analog analogy with human kids,
it's not hopeless like telling,
telling your kids,
these are the 10 things that are important doesn't work that well,
right?
What we're,
what works better is you enter into shared situations with them.
They see how you deal with the situations,
you guide them in dealing with real situations.
And that forms that our system of values,
and this is what needs to happen with Ai,
is they need to grow up entering into real life situations with human beings.
So the real life patterns of human values,
which are worth a lot more than the homily,
is that that we and annunciate formally,
right?
The real life pattern of human values gets inculcated like into the intellectual
DNA of the,
of the AI systems.
And this is part of what worries me about the way the AI field is going at at
this moment.
Because I mean most of the really powerful narrow ais on the planet now are
involved with like selling people stuff they don't need spying on.
People are like figuring out who should be killed or otherwise abused by some
government.
Right?
So if,
if the early stage Ai's that we build turned into general intelligences
gradually,
and these general intelligence is our,
you know,
spy agents and advertising agents,
then like what,
what,
what mindset do these early stage Ai's have as they grow up?